Most people stare up
into space with wonder.
Yet we have this almost alien world
on our own planet.
Just teeming with life.
It's a world completely
out of sight and out of mind.
I have the utmost respect for corals.
They're really sophisticated animals.
Coral is a fundamental part
of a huge ecosystem.
They continue living as long as
their environment allows them to.
There's this big heat wave
that's traveling around
all over the world.
The coral bleaches..
and what you're seeing
is its skeleton underneath.
It's like your body temperature changing.
That's the seriousness of the issue.
So we're sending two teams
to put cameras down
and capture this bleaching event.
The wind and the storm is really
the controlling factor right now.
The wind just took us.
The stern anchor didn't hold.
It's just demolished.
You're working
in an environment every single day
that humans weren't built for.
Your body is cut up
and then you open your eyes.
And it's dead as far as you can see.
We don't have any time to waste
if we want to have any hope.
We live at a unique moment
in time where we can change history.
It's not too late for coral reefs.
This has got to wake up the world.